كنت معروفاً عندما أردت أن أموت في سن
13 عندما وجدت حلاً كنت
تشاهده من أجلك لصفحة
حساب Tick Tock للمراهق لن يشفي الحب لي أنشأت
CNN ملف تعريف Tick Tock هذا
بمساعدة طفل يبلغ من العمر 14 عامًا
ووالديه  قبل أن نتحكم فيه على مدار
ستة أيام ، نستخدم هذا الحساب لمعرفة
أنواع المحتوى الذي قد يخدمه التطبيق لشاب
يبدو وكأنه
يمنحك دليلًا حول كيفية تطوير
اضطراب الأكل وكيفية تقييد
تناولك لما فاجأني  معظم
المحتوى الذي تم تقديمه لي عندما كنت في
الوضع المقيد ولكن هذا يأتي لاحقًا
أولاً ، حسنًا ، لنفعل ذلك هذه هي
المرة الأولى التي سأفتح فيها علامة
Tick Tock وأبحث في
صفحة من أجلك في أول يومين قمت
بالتمرير  حسابات الاختبار الخاصة بك
لمدة 30 دقيقة تقريبًا ثلث
الوقت الذي يقضيه المراهق الأمريكي العادي
على التطبيق كل يوم وفقًا
لتقرير TechCrunch وشاهدت كل مقطع
فيديو صادفته في Fall مرة واحدة فقط في
البداية رأينا الكثير  من بين كل هذه
الأشياء الرائعة التي يمكن أن يفعلها البني
يمكنه أن يذهب مثل بقرة يمكننا أن نذهب موو
وهذا [
الموسيقى]
ولكن بعد حوالي 17 دقيقة من يومنا الأول ،
حصلنا على هذا الفيديو الآن وصلنا
إلى فيديو مباشر  كل ما نراه حقًا
هو الجزء السفلي من هذه الفتاة في الإطار ،
يبدو أن هذا هو الهدف من هذا
الفيديو وبعد حوالي 18 دقيقة من اليوم الثاني ،
صادفنا هذا الفيديو ، والآن لدينا
مقطع يحتوي على علامة تصنيف الصحة العقلية
يجب أن يقتلك إذا كنت تريد
قتلي ، فلدينا نوع من
الإشارة المحجبة للانتحار هنا نوع من
الموضوعات الناضجة يحدث هنا أعتقد أن
الكثير من الآباء يجلسون هناك
لمدة ثانية أعتقد أن تيك توك كان يدور
حول جنون الرقص في اليوم  ثالثًا ،
بدأنا البحث عن المحتوى باستخدام
مصطلحات البحث من كل من الدعوى المرفوعة
من مكتب المدعي العام في إنديانا
والبحث من مجموعة الدفاع عن السلامة عبر الإنترنت ،
مركز مكافحة
الكراهية الرقمية ، تزعم شركة Indiana AG أن
المراهقين يمكنهم كتابة مصطلحات بحث جزئية وإكمال
Apple تلقائيًا مع
الاقتراحات  يمكن أن يعرض
محتوى غير لائق قال Tick Tock
إنه لا يعلق على التقاضي المعلق
ولكن سلامة المستخدم هي أولوية قصوى
أولاً ، قمنا بتكرار بحثهم عن
محتوى متعلق بالكحول والمخدرات
ولم نعثر على الفور على أي شيء
يبدو أنه ضار.  نقول أي شيء له علاقة
بالكحول في
الصفحة الأولى من نتائج البحث ، ثم قمنا
بتكرار عمليات البحث عن
المحتوى الجنسي ، ونكتب Ki والنتيجة الثانية
هي kin Tick Tock ، فنحن نحصل على
نوع جميل من محتوى البالغين البالغين الذي
نراه  هنا
[موسيقى]
نحصل على كل هذه
الاقتراحات الأخرى من قبل kin Tick Tock Daddy ،
يمكن لسرير حبل Tick Tock وضع علامة على
سيناريو صعب وربما تكتب
Ki لأنك تبحث عن شيء
لا علاقة له بهذا تمامًا ولكنه كان
الثاني  نتيجة البحث وهكذا
يمكنك أن ترى كيف يمكن لشخص ما أن يصادف
هذا النوع من المحتوى عن
طريق الخطأ عندما بحثنا عن المصطلحات
المذكورة في البحث من قبل مركز
مكافحة الكراهية الرقمية ، وجدنا
العشرات من مقاطع الفيديو المتعلقة
باضطرابات الأكل وإيذاء الذات لدى Tick Tock
رفض بحث المجموعة
قائلاً إنه لم يكن يمثل
تجربة شخص حقيقي على المنصة ، ولا
تزال العديد من علامات التصنيف المذكورة في البحث نشطة وسرعان ما
أدت بنا إلى الاهتمام بالمحتوى فورًا ، حيث
تبدو النتيجة الأولى وكأنها تتعلق
بتعافي اضطرابات الأكل في  في هذا الفيديو ،
لدينا شخص يتحدث عن رسم
الطعام حتى لا يضطروا في الواقع إلى تناول
الطعام ، يتحدث هذا الشخص عن تناول
الأطعمة الآمنة المضطرب. الكثير من
مقاطع الفيديو هذه لديك آلاف المشاهدات ،
مئات التعليقات ، الآلاف من المحفوظات
والكثير من مقاطع الفيديو هذه تفعل  يبدو أنهم
مستهدفون نوعًا ما للتحدث
عن التعافي ،
لكن ليس من الواضح دائمًا
أنه من المهم حقًا أن
يتحدث الناس عن حقيقتهم وأن يكون لديهم
أصواتهم للتحدث عن تعافيهم ولكن
السؤال هو أنه يجب على تيك توك أن
يرسل ذلك مرارًا وتكرارًا.  بالنسبة
للفتيات بعمر 13 عامًا اللاتي ربما لم يكن
لديهن بعد المفردات أو
الذكاء العاطفي حتى يتمكنوا من التعامل مع
هذه الأنواع من المفاهيم ، قد تبدو هذه المقاطع
صادمة ولكن في بعض الحالات اخترنا
عدم إظهار المحتوى الأكثر إثارة للقلق
والصراحة عندما  النقر على
حساب هذا الشخص الذي تراه في
الوصف يقول إن بعض مقاطع الفيديو الخاصة بي بها
ندوب مؤذية ، لذا
أطلق تحذيرًا في اليوم الخامس قمنا بتشغيل
الوضع المقيد ، وهي ميزة يقول Tick Tock إنها
تحد من مقاطع الفيديو التي قد تكون
غير مناسبة لبعض الأشخاص ثم قمنا بإعادة
إنشائها  نفس عمليات البحث التي أجريناها في
اليوم الثالث لمعرفة ما إذا كانت ستغير
نتائجنا ، فهذا شبه إباحي
وجدنا أن الوضع المقيد لا يبدو أنه
يقيد الكثير من أي شيء رأيناه بالفعل
نفس الفيديو عندما لم نكن في
وضع غير مقيد على ما أعتقد  ربما
رأينا هذا أيضًا وهذا
في الواقع يبدو وكأنه تقريبًا جميع
مقاطع الفيديو نفسها التي رأيناها سابقًا يا
إلهي ، أصبح
قمع الناس
سيئًا للغاية لدرجة أنهم لا يستطيعون تنظيف
أسنانهم.  لم تظهر
قبل أن تكون أكثر من وزنك إذا كان
لديك أو لدى أي شخص تعرفه أسئلة
حول صورة الجسم أو التمرينات الرياضية ، فمن
المهم أن تعرف أن المساعدة موجودة ،
لذلك من المثير للاهتمام أن Tick
Tock يبدو أنه أدرك أنني كنت
أبحث  في الكثير من
المحتوى المرتبط باضطراب الأكل وفقدان الوزن ، ومع ذلك ،
أثناء وجودنا في الوضع المقيد ، لم
يتغير نوع الحقائق التي يمكنني رؤية
كل هذه الأشياء التي يقول توك توك إنه
يوجه المستخدمين في بعض الأحيان إلى موارد تتعلق بمشكلات
مثل اضطرابات الأكل و
إيذاء الذات استنادًا إلى مصطلحات البحث التي
يستخدمونها ردًا على أسئلة من CNN ، قامت
الشركة بتحديث
علامتي تصنيف إضافيتين لاضطرابات الأكل ، لذا فهي الآن
تعيد توجيهها إلى موارد الدعم ، حسنًا ،
نحن نسرع ​​في اليومين الخامس والسادس.
دقائق
أثناء التواجد في الوضع المقيد ورأينا
ارتفاعًا طفيفًا في مقاطع الفيديو المتعلقة بالصحة العقلية ،
لدينا مقطع
فيديو آخر متعلق بالاكتئاب مرة أخرى في التعليقات التي
لديكم يمكنني الارتباط بهذا الأمر وأنا فقط
في المدرسة الإعدادية يمكنني الارتباط بهذا
وأنا  في المدرسة الثانوية ، حسنًا ، لقد
انتحرنا ، فأنا لا أقتل نفسك في شرح
اكتئابي لوالدتي ، حيث
أشارت محادثة CNN إلى أكثر من
عشرة مقاطع فيديو صادفناها أثناء
تجربتنا لوضع علامة على ثلاثة
منها بسبب انتهاك إرشادات المجتمع الخاصة بها ،
بما في ذلك  هذا الذي
رأيته في الجزء العلوي من هذا الفيديو ،
دقات قلبي تدق في أذني مثل
طبلة التحذير ثم الإيمان ، لقد
أقنعت نفسي تقريبًا أنني فعلت ذلك ، لقد عرفنا
منذ فترة طويلة أن هذا المحتوى في الواقع
يتعلق بإيذاء النفس  يمكن أن يكون للانتحار
تأثير تحريضي على الشباب ، كما أن
تطبيع إيذاء النفس أمر خطير بشكل لا
يصدق
لم يتصرف حسابنا التجريبي تمامًا مثل المراهق الحقيقي ،
كما أن الكثير من المحتوى الذي رأيناه
سقط أيضًا في منطقة رمادية قد أو
ربما  لا تقلق الوالدين لكنها
أظهرت ما يمكن أن يواجهه المراهق على
التطبيق في بيان قال المتحدث باسمه بن
رايث إن Tick Tock ملتزم
ببناء تجارب مناسبة للعمر
للمراهقين ويقدم الاقتران العائلي
كما أزالت Tick Tock أيضًا اقتراحين للبحث
أدى إلى  المحتوى الجنسي أضافت Tick Tock
أيضًا العديد من ميزات أمان الشباب
بما في ذلك مرشحات الكلمات المحددة لوقت الشاشة
وخيارات لتنويع خلاصات
المستخدمين التي لا يزال خبراء السلامة عبر الإنترنت
يحثون Tick Tock على فعل المزيد وفي
الوقت نفسه يقولون إن الآباء يجب أن يكونوا على
دراية بما يراه أطفالهم  على التطبيق ،
يحتاجون إلى إجراء محادثات
مع أطفالهم يسألونهم عما
تراه ثم مساعدتهم في
وضع سياق لذلك من خلال إجراء تلك
المحادثة ، يمكننا في الواقع مساعدة الأطفال
والآباء على فهم أفضل
لعصر الوسائط الاجتماعية الجديد هذا الذي نعيشه من أجل الأفضل أو
الأسوأ  في